guy with the based mother and how smart
she is and how she is grown into a woman
of intellect that's a lot of compliments
that is like the coolest thing we
started this YouTube Journey what about
a month and a half ago now the plan
we're still in phase one yeah it's all
coming into fruition so far we're at
about almost 25 000 subscribers on
YouTube 50 million views on tick tock
not too shabby for like a month into
this John no I'm saying I'm just playing
with my dollhouse it's gonna be hanging
so not bad the Tates reacted to us the
other day we already posted that
reaction video make sure to go check
that one out if you haven't already and
they just reacted to us again today so
it's pretty cool it's surprising it is
pretty dope yeah not a lot of people no
I think it's cool I appreciate it and
and you know we're we're really on the
same page a lot about a lot of stuff
let's hear let's hear it I want to see
what they said yeah I'm excited let's go
another name of a man who has a pretty
good track I could never say he was
right by everything it's funny he's been
banned too real funny interesting I'm
interested in the name you can guess the
name you absolutely can right so anybody
who's serious about tenant number 25 and
the 41 tenants who serious about making
money go to corporate.com sign up to the
mailing list also we're gonna leave this
telegram Channel at em live chat this
will be a live this will be live and
online for the next 72 hours anyone
watches this even if you don't watch it
live we are live and online right now
ready to speak to you as right now we're
in real time you can interact with
somebody on my side who's outside of the
Matrix who's in the real world who can
explain to you exactly how you can break
free now I have two questions one of
which I can answer are you guys Time
Travelers um if you watch emergency
meeting episode 11 this is now episode
three because these are the episodes of
matter where we can speak truthfully on
episode 11 we were asked if the CERN uh
Large Hadron Collider
um teleport us here from the dimension
and we already confirmed that to be true
so yes two I'm gonna throw a little
curveball at your end because a lot of
people are asking you about this man uh
what you think of a minute you should do
an episode why is it happening so fast I
only listened to stuff in in Faster
speed needs so I didn't even notice that
was going too fast until you mentioned
it what are you gonna do got things to
do I got places to be practicing
double snap you watch your apps
exploding in real time on your phone
just exploding boom boom boom I've
started to notice something
oh the last podcast we talked about the
guy with the based mother and how smart
she is and how she is grown into a woman
of intellect and she is not taking [ __ ]
from the world anymore and through her
experiences she's developed a fantastic
[ __ ] detector she's just like
[ __ ] and raise Emerald [ __ ] raised a
son and raise the son to do the same
thing so that's a fantastic uh example
of amazing parenting and you can check
out the check out their Channel that's a
lot of compliments that is like the
coolest [ __ ] thing that's a lot about
this husband this has not clicked in my
head that these two like have watched
our videos and I'm not trying to sound
like a fanboy or nothing but like this
[ __ ] is nuts because like I put this
plan together a couple months ago after
I left my last company to put my full
focus on the content build up the
university and do all of this stuff and
it's like crazy seeing it all come it's
really wonderful as your mother watching
your plans come true fruition but it
kind of just goes back to your work
ethic and you're not just you're not
just that you work hard but working
smart and I find it really like I said
you know I said in one of the videos
recently you inspire me and I'm really
excited and I get a little bit weird
about taking compliments and that's
something I've always worked at and uh I
get a little shy and weird around it and
those are just some really big
compliments coming from guys who I think
are very smart intelligent like also
have an excellent [ __ ] meter so I
I'm really yeah just I'm a little wow
I'm a little feeling flustered and kind
of blushing a little right now I can
feel the red of my face yeah this this
[ __ ] hasn't really clicked yet because I
also like we were talking about this at
dinner like we haven't been recognized
in person or anything once yet because
we've kind of just been like staying
inside and grinding we're staying with
our Grandma's house my grandma's house
in New Jersey right now
I feel like it's it's gonna be like once
I move to Miami and I'm starting to like
go out and socialize a lot more again
like what this the first time I get
recognized it's gonna become like a
regular occurrence for both of us I'm
gonna stay under this because at that
point we're gonna be like really big I'm
gonna hide you're gonna you're gonna
stay in hiding sorry we'll move to
Romania and just chill with the Tates
you can get recognized I'm gonna stay in
hiding because actually I really enjoy
meeting people but like I said I still
have this like getting it I have a
trouble getting attention uh believe it
or not it is weird no I know exactly
what you mean so that anyway wow grass
let's go right back at you fire me up
another woman what's been sticking up
for me today I got sent a video and it's
almost like I've been contingent of
women who are smart intelligent they've
been through enough life to detect
[ __ ] when they see it and they're
the ones who know that my Banning and my
censoring for being dangerous is
completely not really unfair and it's
very interesting to see this group stand
out because most people especially the
men who come at me have this idea that
all women hate me and a bunch of
attractive young beautiful women came
out and said no we love Tate he's a nice
guy and then on top of that now we have
this new contingent of women who are
very very intelligent lived a very very
good life we're very very successful
we're sitting around saying No this is
[ __ ] there was no reason to ban this
man well so for that reason I want to
put this one yeah put it on screen but I
would imagine I don't know this based
mom this woman who you're about to play
I don't know this but one would imagine
and I I would imagine that the men that
they chose to spend their lives with and
to procreate with and to have children
with if I could guess and I would be
right would be men who probably agreed
with
all uh some if not all of the of the
tenants of taking something you just put
up yeah this is not the best mom she's
still around she's still doing videos
we're gonna keep an eye on the channel
and and promote everything we can for
them but this is uh another very
intelligent lady
it's pretty Kick-Ass though that's
that's where they talk about us but holy
[ __ ] yeah that was very cool this is not
the based mom but another very cool lady
I want to see this lady let's see her I
wanna I wanna see and I gotta say um
maybe we got a future buddy here let's
talk some more about Andrew Tai you
interviewed some teenage boys about him
and your own boys yeah watch some of it
right so let me finish we bookmarked and
it'll segue into the teenage boys I
interviewed okay so you said you know
basically what he does like he's like
the sledgehammer version to our filigree
silver Nutcracker right right no that's
something that'll do it it's a terrible
analogy that's okay we'll go with that
okay so he takes quite a blunt approach
to things like you can't trust the
government this crisis is overblown it's
all about control breakthrough The
Matrix be successful overcome depression
it's all really good stuff actually
he's not appealing to a tiny audience
you've got to bear in mind he had 4.7
million followers on Instagram I don't
know a teenage boy who doesn't follow
um Andrew Tate so my own sons have been
showing me videos for ages now any
parent knows that a high profile
cancellation isn't going to fix a
culture of misogyny overnight forget it
it's an ongoing process a conversation
exploratory conversation gentle
conversation questions so he's actually
said a lot of things that my sons have
found inspiring and I consider to be
positive he also says things that I
consider to be less positive I think his
brother might run a webcam business so
that's led into a big conversation about
prostitution about webcam work about
politics about how it's been useful but
do you worry that his influence on your
children for example would include the
fact that he that they might then take
up his views of of women because there's
no doubt that he is very disparaging and
dismissive of women right and you know
obviously as parents does our job to
make sure that doesn't sit with their
points of view but it can do okay a
couple of things first of all people
really underestimate kids all the time I
go to schools I do school talks I think
this generation are incredibly media
Savvy media literate they're intelligent
we shouldn't underestimate them my sons
think that some of what he says is a
comic Persona some of what he says is
outrageous but they're not stupid kids
aren't stupid they take the good with
the bad like I said you just because
he's not on Instagram anymore that
doesn't mean that every teenage boy in
the country can't go into PornHub and
see women being slapped and slapped and
caught the worst names under the sun and
treated like
crap but maybe that's not the bit
they're taking from it maybe they're
taking that as part of the package and
they'll find him wherever he is I mean
is he findable now he's on Rumble and
when he moved to rumble rumble's daily
traffic went up nearly 50 right the
thing is what it will do is constrain
his reach so whereas before yeah I mean
she's she's thoughtful can you process
you know she's thoughtful she seems to
be looking at things you know deeper
than the average person and willing to
really have a conversation she also
she's pretty she has a lovely accent and
her name is called Ron dodsworth she
sounds far more distinguished you need
to put a drink in her hand you'd be
under tens and the hundreds of thousands
the thing is so when you make less money
then probably ultimately but he's
already extremely wealthy the thing is
you can take him off social media you
have not made the world a safer place
what you've done is in effect radicalize
a generation of young men they were not
radicalized by his message I tell you
what they're radicalized by they are
incredibly cynical about why he's been
removed from social media I interviewed
several teenage boys about this
what they think is that Andrew Tate was
too powerful and they recognize that
governments have people removed from the
internet they don't like and they are
not wrong because that is fantastic I
hope that's true I hope young people are
coming to a point where they look at
this and they go governments this is
overreach and they're afraid of powerful
people and they really see it for what
it is and I think that's what's
happening
I think it really it definitely gives me
a jolt of inspiration to think that
young people are getting Savvy enough to
see this because you know we're living
in you know well at the moment we're in
Jersey but we've been living in
Massachusetts for Sonny's whole life and
it's really been hard to see the youth
just brainwashed by liberal propaganda
yeah it's really fascinating I thought I
was nuts everyone used to look at me
like I'm crazy I remember this one kid
at the peak BLM and covet and everything
so senior year cut it up sure it's fine
it's just the job so at the peak of like
the BLM stuff this kid posted on his
Instagram Story how BLM is a scam and
how it's just being used for the
election and this kid like couldn't go
to school anymore because people hated
him so much and I remember dming him I'm
like bro you're not wrong I was talking
to him in class amazing how it
disappeared as soon as the election was
over and all of a sudden and then and
then he's portrayed as this big racer
after the election was over
cancellations on social media really
slowed down and almost went away and now
all of a sudden they've got Tate they've
got snico they I'm sure there's a whole
list of people that have an open you
know they're opening their mouths that
are getting canceled we're on the list
we're getting there so is it not a
coincidence that is happening right at
midterm elections in the United States
because we've got for those of you that
aren't here in the states we've got big
elections coming up regarding that will
affect our Congress in November and a
lot of gubernatorial elections and you
know local state elections that that
really matter and all of a sudden the
free thinkers are being shut down how
convenient I know one of the things that
he argues for
um however in the way of the modern sort
of media that we now have debate isn't
really a thing is it you know Russell
Brand makes videos is basically Russell
Brand talking to a camera in the same
way that I presume Andrew Tate does that
they're not really interested in debate
they're interested in influencing people
so with debate you don't do that because
with debate you make people think what
he's doing is making people just you
wasn't into this no no no he is not when
he has a detractor online he responds to
it it may not be a live debate but he
also does go on other people's podcasts
and talk to them oh he said he doesn't
do that he said that he just basically
is talking into a camera and and is
resists actual debate well these people
so this guy so this is this is this is a
guy who maybe [ __ ] great journalists
who the hell knows but I can tell you
what's happening with him right now he's
stodgy and he's stuck in his old ways
and he doesn't realize that you can have
a debate without actually being close to
each other nowadays that the kids taken
media differently so a debate can be a
YouTube war where you say you you know
Tate says something and then somebody
says something bad about him and then
take responds to it in another video and
that grows everybody's channels and
there's all methods of the madness this
guy doesn't see that so he just says
okay it's not willing to debate even
though it does do debate get in the ring
and Tate will get in the ring and beat
the living [ __ ] and get out of somebody
and fight to the death near death thank
God he's not dead but he'll also I would
bet my soul that Tate would not be
afraid to sit across the table from
anybody and have a debate with them the
guy's intelligent he's quick-witted he's
fast on his feet he knows what he's
talking about and he's solid in his
convictions so this guy again did zero
homework on tape zero so intelligent
intelligent it's amazing how there are
some people in the world who are
prepared and capable of resisting Mass
hysteria and using their brains and some
people who are just literally empty
vessels waiting to be told what to think
yeah it's quite impressive but yeah this
is a very very intelligent very smart
woman she said some very intelligent
things
all right guys thank you so much for
watching make sure to join the Discord
subscribe there's like we're getting
like 100 000 views of video and we're at
20 000 subscribers hit the button I
really appreciate it thank you guys for
subscribing and watching and liking for
my poor mother my boy from my little boy
hit the button because if I die he's
gonna be able to take care of himself
that's my whole maternal philosophy you
don't take care of me I'm taking care of
you don't get out of here yeah because I
taught you how to be self-sufficient
yeah so also make sure to follow us on
Rumble just in case YouTube keeps taking
down our videos which they have been
doing so yeah we post our videos there
and that's all I'm glad you're on your
phone now all right see you later
[Music]